the other basic principles and rules of
lockdown remain for now the same unless
you're doing exercise or performing
another essential tasks such as buying
food or medicine you should stay at home
and you should not meet up with people
from other households because that is
how we give the virus a chance to spread
and give it bridges that it can travel
over them and lead to increased spread
so the change that I have confirmed
today is the only change the Scottish
government judges that it is safe to
make right now without risking a rapid
resurgence of the virus we do not at
this point want to see more businesses
opening up or more people going to work
our guidance to business remains for now
the same as it has been and we are not
yet changing who can or should be at
school now you may hear the Play
Minister announced other immediate
changes for England at later tonight and
that is absolutely his right to do so I
have just come from a cobra meeting with
the Prime Minister and the First
Minister's of Wales and Northern Ireland
now it's important to say that I don't
expect the detail of these immediate
changes that the Prime Minister will
announce to be significant and I predict
there any differences with the position
here in Scotland will be relatively
minor however for the avoidance of doubt
let me be clear except for the one
change I have confirmed today the rules
here have not changed we remain in
lockdown for now and my ask or view
remains to stay at home however we will
continue to monitor the evidence closely
and make further changes as soon as we
considered it safe to do so